we must i'm afraid look again at
christmas and
as prime minister it's my duty to take
difficult decisions
to do what is right to protect the
people
of this country given the early evidence
we have
on this new variant of the virus the
potential
risk it poses it is with a very heavy
heart i must tell you we cannot
continue with christmas as planned
in england those living in tier 4 areas
should not mix
with anyone outside their own household
at christmas
though support bubbles will remain in
place for those of particular risk of
loneliness
or isolation across the rest of the
country
the christmas rules allowing up to three
households to meet
will now be limited to christmas day
only
rather than the five days as previously
set out
as before there will be no relaxation on
the 31st of january
so people must not break the rules at
new year
they must they must not break the rules
in new york it's very very important to
to emphasize that i know
how much emotion people invest
in this time of year and
how important it is for instance for
grandparents to see
their grandchildren for families to be
together
so i know how disappointing this will be
but we have said
throughout this pandemic that we must
and we will be
guided by the science
when the science changes we must change
our response when the virus changes
its method of attack we must change
our method of defense
and as your prime minister i sincerely
believe there is no alternative
open to me without action
the evidence suggests that infections
would soar hospitals
would become overwhelmed and many
thousands more
would lose their lives and i want to
stress that we are not
alone in this fight or in taking these
types of
decisions many of our european friends
and neighbors
are being forced to take similar action
we're working closely with the devolved
administrations to protect people
in every part of the uk and of course
there is now real real hope
that we will soon be rid of
this virus and that prospect is growing
with every day that passes and every
vaccine dose that
is administered as you know the uk was
the first country
in the western world to start using a
clinically approved
vaccine and so please if the nhs
contacts you then get your vaccine
and join the 350 000 people across the
uk who have already had
their first dose yes
christmas this year will be different
very different but we must be realistic
we're sacrificing the chance to see our
loved ones
this christmas so we have a better
chance
of protecting their lives so that we can
see them
at future christmases and
as sure as night follows day uh we'll
beat back this
virus will defeat it and reclaim our
life